hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game Asian series so
last time we took a look at I am GUI
events definitely check out that video
if you haven't already we implemented
all of the events that we wanted to do
flying two weeks but we can actually
interact with it and use it inside hazel
that's all done now which is pretty cool
and today check this out I've got a bit
of a different set that's because my
place is currently getting a little bit
of a renovation done and so to go that
everything's kind of just all over the
place I'm staying here for the time
being and because of that I thought that
I would kind of use this opportunity
since I'm so busy with all the
renovation stuff and didn't really get a
chance to make a proper episode I guess
some people call it proper episode it's
today we could just kind of take a look
at the github repository that it's hazel
and kind of just because I really
haven't even spent an episode on that
yet I'm gonna kind of go through that
and see all of the kind of issues and
pull requests that people have made I'll
introduce a lot of the things that will
actually be doing on that github and how
I want you guys I guess to submit to
collaborate with me on hazel and then
we'll also just implement some of those
fixes I guess inside this video because
I've been meaning to do that in like for
such a long time and I feel oh this is
perfect because this doesn't require me
spending hours preparing for the episode
I can just kind of just do this on the
fly and see what we have available to us
on github and the just this week is just
perfect for doing that so let's just
jump in and take a look at that github
repository and see what we can actually
do ok so this is the github repository
for hazel if you guys aren't familiar
with that the link is in the description
of every single video of this series
which just github.com for slash the
channel - hazel so we have this github
repository which contains a little bit
code now I do want to give you guys a
bit of a tour to those who aren't as
familiar with git obviously for a lot of
people this is probably your first
github quite a project or git project
justice for the first kind of big
software project in general I know for a
lot of use that's why I kind of want to
give this o be for those of you who
understand how old this works of course
and a more advanced and feel free to not
listen to this information although I
still would because you probably learn
things
that you might not have known okay so
the first thing I want to focus on is
this chemists thing so people ask me
people who watched the series and who
aren't up to date don't necessarily want
to just download the code and take a
look at everything immediately they
actually might want to see what the code
was like as of a certain episode but
guess what you can actually do that if
you go back if you click on that commits
thing and then look at this you have all
the different commits that I've made and
typically I commit once per episode
right so for example the episode about
pre-compile headers well this is this is
that commit right the episode where I
just added you know speed log and all of
that kind of stuff and maybe pre make
and generate projects that is this
commit if you click on this hash here
I'll open it in a new tab you'll see
exactly what's changed so for example I
think this is mostly not code changes
but you can see that I added this pre
make file dissolve Green changes in the
project files this is what changed let's
find a better commit for actual codes
maybe like this dispatching events from
GLW you can see that in the application
does a VP file this is what has changed
right I've added all this green stuff
the red stuff has been removed very cool
right because you can easily see the
changes and if you want to implement it
in you like if you're following along
with this like you should be in typing
out all the code yourself which is
probably the best way to learn you can
see exactly what's changed I'm in case I
need in the workout or whatever we just
want to kind of see exactly what I did
to actually solve a problem you can do
that by just looking at this diff so
that's really really useful but one
thing that people don't know as much is
that you can click on this button which
is right next to it to actually browse
that repository at this point in history
right so again with the pre make one if
I click here I will see this whole
repository as it was you can see you as
of that commit right so that's really
cool because you can then download this
or or if you're actually using get on
the command line for example in your
computer you can actually just check out
this commit specifically right you can
actually do that and you can see that's
kind of the tree I guess you can
actually do that and and just recreate
that version of hey
which is really cool again if you're
following along and you want something a
bit more simple because as time goes on
you know if you're watching this video
and it's like a year from now and hazel
is this huge engine you might still want
to implement the basics and start from
scratch and you can still do that
because you can go through the history
and see what it was like at any given
point in history which is really really
cool so a lot of people don't know that
so I just wanted to kind of make that
clear okay the next thing I want to talk
about is all this kind of collaboration
opportunity right because I have
actually I do actually intend on using
this I want hazel to be a project that
we work on together and github
facilitates a lot of kind of common
software engineering processes I guess
as far as teamwork and collaboration
goes so we basically have three or four
even main things here we have issues
pull requests projects and the wiki so
we'll start with issues issues are just
like essentially anything any tasks or
problems or questions or whatever that
are related to the development of hazel
are usually discussed here and just
raised here so if you find a bug in
hazel you should open any issue here
right as time goes on I will start
adding things like labels and I'll kind
of just customize this list to make it a
little bit more usable for us obviously
I'm not using this yet and there's even
milestones which are these basically
collections of issues and pull requests
for particularly sub projects so there
might be like you know the renderer for
example or maybe like a certain release
we're working towards and we can
basically attach a bunch of issues to
that and say that when all these issues
are complete that means that that's it
when all these issues are closed the
release is ready to go or the renderer
is complete or whatever which is really
cool and again I intend on using this
stuff in the future as well but we'll go
through these actual real issues in a
minute here but that's basically what
issues are just a little kind of you
know oh hey I was wondering about this
or you know I found a problem in hazel
and just wanted to let you know that if
you click you know if you try and scroll
in I am gooey or whatever it doesn't
work sometimes yeah that kind of
stuff full requests are code that people
have actually written that typically
either implement features or I guess
more often fixed little things so for
example this is a great example the star
project this person has added sub her to
be sandbox in pre make okay so if we
look at the files changed you can say
that in pre make they've just added
these two lines of code here that
basically set sandbox as a start up
project in Visual Studio so that we
don't have to like you know go to UM
sandbox and then right-click and set a
start up project because a lot of people
actually I think hazel ends up coming up
as a start up project or whatever people
try and like run that um and then they
get this error which says unable to stop
program because obviously you're trying
to run a DLL file which is just a
library and you need to run the next
cutable file so that's like a really
great fix right really simple really
easy I'm not like I certainly don't
intend to just kind of be like oh yeah
this is a good idea let me just
integrate that myself know why it's a
pull request
it's obviously has no conflicts and can
be merged easily
why wouldn't I merge that right so I do
intend on again getting help from you
guys add learning support to the project
stuff like this might be a little bit
more complicated you know this person's
added a bunch of make files I would
probably need to actually test this and
make sure it works properly that's a bit
of work so that might be something that
isn't trivial and something that we
might want to explore more and then you
know stuff like a today make supporter
project I think I actually replied to
this saying that we would use pre Meg
but maybe that was in issue I don't
remember usually for large tasks like
this it's better to open up an issue
first and to actually just make sure
that this is in fact the direction we
want to go in so I think well maybe it
wasn't that one because I definitely
remember commenting ages ago on a pre
make else ariana.sea make thing I don't
know who was a portal quest there now
and make sure you obviously look through
these ones I'll search through them if
you if you um you know if you are if
there's something that you want to do
but you don't sure about it I'm really
not comment on this I don't believe that
I guess I didn't huh look at that I
thought I did anyway yeah so you know
that's a great idea for example cuz we
don't need that pre-made can actually
generate so you make files anyway so
that's that but anyway poor replace are
for that kind of stuff
right so if there's little tasks or just
even large tasks that people want to
kind of do then I'm happy to take a look
at that
obviously stuff like add Linux support
of the project that would require an
entire episode probably to go through so
I'm not sure how that would fit in
please be patient with me regarding this
stuff because obviously I have my own
kind of agenda and plan as to how I'm
writing hazel and if suddenly I need to
look over this then that will take time
and I don't know how often that episode
anywhere again I wish I was talking this
stuff full-time um that would let me do
stuff like that
but at the moment this is just how it is
projects are really cool as well it
gives you like a little bit of a Trello
board essentially so that you can kind
of add issues to certain things plan
your projects I'm not gonna read all
these features you can read that
yourself but the idea is just gives it
like a bunch of cards and I think
there's even some examples maybe if you
had to learn more yeah yeah basically
something like this right we sure wish
again is really cool I intend on fully
using this right now we're just doing
the basics so I don't think there's a
huge need to do this and I'll probably
end up doing most of this stuff offline
I don't know let me know let me know
what you think about that let me know if
I should show how I make all of this in
a video or if it's something that I can
just do kind of offline you know while
I'm on the train or something because
again that's up to you guys I'm happy to
do it in a video in front of you if you
want to kind of see this and you want to
see me kind of talk through all this
stuff and like you know what I'm
thinking about certain issues and tasks
and how I prioritize that kind of stuff
the wiki again useless right now because
hazel is like well I mean maybe not
useless because maybe there could be
like a bit of a more extended readme
here as to how to actually set up hazel
and build it because again you know if
you look at the discord if you look at
my discord server there's so many people
you know not being able to kind of run
haze or having issues with hazel which
again out trivial fixes because like a
really a common one I've seen at least
five times is
because this is the total project and
people just don't know that you need to
set it to sandbox which again hopefully
will be fixed because of that that pull
request but you get the point so that
might be something of the Hazel wiki I
might be useful again something that um
you know I mean great can create the
first page now and just save it but that
will kind of just make the wiki and you
can see now suddenly like the wikis just
up so anyone can edit this anyone can
have pages I'm pretty sure so feel free
to kind of you know write down stuff
there I'll obviously have to moderate it
and I've got a bunch of moderators as
well it'll help me out with that
but um yeah I plan on obviously having a
lot of kind of information here as well
so that's an overview of all the kind of
stuff that github has for us so now
let's kind of go through these and see
if we can actually implement them into
hazel and fix them up so Mac OS support
these are the issues not the border
quests so just quickly really quickly
read this so I've only use the code in
Xcode and Mac if there's a way of course
so yeah again pre mega Xcode four should
work now I believe that I probably have
made specific things here that are
Windows only I think if you look at
entry point which is here yeah Carly's
got if def edges at platform windows
because I haven't tested this stuff on
that so don't know if it will work on
Mac I do plan on doing an actual pass on
other operating systems very soon
probably Linux maybe first because Mac
having a Mac actually requires Mac
hardware if we exclude hackintosh and I
do have a macbook but it's like I think
from 2013 so it's a little bit old but
we'll see
I might just quickly try and do that for
you guys anyway um and once I've done
that that's what I usually like to add
stuff like that like for example when
I'm running in Visual Studio right now I
don't really like to do stuff like you
know else if H that platform Mac OS or
something like that I'm just because I
can test that code anyway and I don't
want to just write code so um if you
look at this actual code there's nothing
really you know window specific in it so
if you take away this this if deaf or
just add something like you know or math
right
to find edge that platform windows or
you know mac then um it should actually
work but again I haven't tested that and
that's something like different
operating systems will be something I
would do in the proper version again
would be probably to do something like
that with a macro because eventually we
may want to have specific windows stuff
here for example we may want to actually
have the wind main function instead of
just men because we may want to do some
special kind of some more closer
integration with the actual windows
ecosystem so that there's kind of my
thoughts there and then obviously
actually I guess it won't work though in
general because hazel API right now if
we go through what is this colloidal age
this only supports Windows right now and
we have decals back DLL export instead
of the appropriate attributes or
whatever for clanging for the Mac OS
kind of Xcode client compiler it's like
a special version of clang essentially
but it is mostly cute it's mostly
claimed it was it just clangs so
basically for clang we need different
compiler intrinsics and not just decals
back so again something that needs to be
done and something that will be probably
done quite soon but again just for now I
just want to set up a base kind of
framework and then from there I'll
extend it to cover Mac as well and Linux
because for now as I've kind of
mentioned hazel is going to be kind of
Windows only for the first like
milestone maybe
and again milestones is something like a
document will be here but for the first
little while hazel is gonna be Windows
only because it's better to just focus
on one platform and get a bunch of stuff
running rather than waste time on a lot
of other platforms and then just get
nowhere because again this is a video
series I need to keep this entertaining
and I need to keep this project going I
don't have much time to begin with so
it's a lot better to just actually have
most people happy because most people
are using Windows and then people who
are using Mac OS can just add themselves
if they really want to do anyway that's
my opinion on that issue I might write a
comment I don't wanna do it in this
video just not waste time but that's how
that's what that is like yes so what a
core and client loggers have to be
shared points have unique pointers you
I mean because that returns a shared
pointer if we look at the log dot H you
can see that this s core it's a share is
a shared pointer so we returned this we
return it by reference because we don't
need to increment the reference count
where it is referencing it right we're
not actually transferring ownership or
getting ownership of this core logger I
always want the ownership to be held by
log and it's static anyway so it will be
the lifetime of this actual module but
yeah that is all I want is access to it
hence the return by reference thing I
you could return by value and just have
it in a scope I personally don't like
doing that usually I use other forms of
reference counting like in like
intrusive ref counts that are actually
part of the object so in that case
usually I do return by reference when I
don't want that ref count to increment
because why make a copy of this there's
no ownership going on here at all I'm
simply retired simply want access radar
any kind of access to this nor ownership
transfer at all so I will like this
comment and I can probably close this
issue because that's the answer right
there okay so build fails when building
for the first time yeah this is quite an
issue I've seen and in this przemek
video basically what happens is and I
can demonstrate this to you guys is if
you try and build you know what's build
sandbox it actually ends up failing
because it can't copy a certain file so
let's look at this okay
that's succeeded that's because let's
just clean this and also I want to maybe
delete pin and pin and plate those
directories let's try again okay so you
can see that failed one failed and there
isn't failed if we scroll up a little
bit you can see it says over here that
that command kind of didn't work so
quick look for that here there it is
there's that error so the command if
exists Beauvoir failed and the solution
to that I guess is just running it again
the reason is that it tries to actually
run that
code before these certain folders have
been created and what that post built
step actually does if we look at the pre
make file is it tries to copy it tries
to copy and this is inside the hazel
project it tries to actually copy the
output I guess into sandbox now the
thing is sandbox hasn't been created yet
right because we haven't compiled
sandbox we've compiled hazel and this is
a post build command on hazel now here's
the thing the reason why this is a post
build command on hazel because this
person says it removes the post build
command on the windows filled from hazel
and put it into the sandbox project
that's what I actually usually ended up
doing now the reason I didn't do that
for hazel is because if you do that and
you make a change to actual hazel and
not to sandbox then it won't actually
copy the latest file because it doesn't
build right sandbox you haven't changed
sandbox there for sandbox itself doesn't
build it's already ready to go
you've changed hazel and because it's a
dynamic library yeah under certain cases
I mean if the whole library file hasn't
changed it has to really uncover see it
will but under certain cases it won't
actually copy it right which is why like
my approach to this was just basically
to say that obviously every time hazel
changes that's when we need to copy that
dll over so do we get the latest version
of it now again in this case San Marsol
doesn't exist so unless someone has a
better solution to this because I I
don't like this either I would rather
just worked maybe we can put a post
build command to actually make that
folder if it doesn't exist or maybe this
copy thing I mean honestly this copy
function should just make directories if
they don't already exist
maybe there's a flag we can add to that
I might explore that again just in my
own time but that's kind of why this is
the way that it is so yeah ok this is
cool I read this I like this to actually
like this no I didn't I'm gonna like it
now pre-make does has how it does have
functions for like static or dynamic
runtime so static runtime on and then
there's also I think
um runtime which again either debug or
not
okay so runtime release for example and
and this that does a non-static link so
this is great because we did some stuff
like this which was really annoying
because this was a multi-threaded debug
DLL link of the runtime library however
if we actually look at and I always
forget what this is I think it's in like
language no it's not so code C is equal
host cogeneration
you can see multi-threaded debug no DLL
here right just MTD but if we go to the
command line we have another write for
it which again really annoying because
it has to let me just kind of make a
change here so that we can recompile it
you can see over here that it says
command line warning it's overriding our
multi-threaded DLL sorry I'm a
multi-threaded debug with multi terrific
multi-threaded debug DLL I don't like
that obviously so what we can do instead
of having this build options flag which
I'm going to remove now is in debug
instead of having MD D now we can just
do runtime debug so runtime debug and I
don't know if um yeah I guess what's to
debug okay and then for this obviously
becomes runtime release now static
runtime static runtime is what we would
use if we wanted a non DLL so just
multi-threaded debug as our option
instead of monitor the debug DLL which
is what we want so that's what we have
to do and then that's way better than MD
and doesn't have to be window specific
here it is for now but it doesn't have
to be because that should work for all
kind of systems so that's that and
that's really cool so thank you for
people who brought that to my attention
I was not fully aware of that
so runtime release and runtime debug and
I think that's it so the /m stuff should
need this anyway so now if we actually
rerun that generate projects and we
reload all of this stuff we should be
able to pop in to say hazel and say that
this is
so this sells multi-threaded debug and
knob debug gala because I think we also
need static on time so runtime is just
which one debugger release and static
runtime on or off you can see sets this
to DOL or not DLL so but if folder must
be on so we also need static runtime I
thought static run time was basically
something that you enabled let me run
reload remake something that you just
enabled for if you wanted static but
apparently not so we can actually just
do this up here so static runtime off
okay and we'll do that for both hazel
and sandbox so now if we rerun our
generate projects and we look at this so
I actually have an override a static
runtime on let's get rid of that this is
becoming annoying it's the sack run time
off is what we want I don't know why I
had that on so static run time off for
both hazel and sandbox
okay now let's generate our projects
there you go succeeded and reload all
and then inside hazel now we have
multi-threaded debug DLL perfect and we
don't need any overrides so let's build
everything now and hopefully this will
all work ok cool you can see that it
succeeded and obviously we don't have
any kind of overrides or anything like
that
brilliant so that is that thank you
letting me know it's been implemented in
the latest video and I'll even do a
little smiley face smile ok brilliant so
I love stuff like that
HSN enable sets never enabled yeah
I know I discussed this on this court as
well so this is something that again H
set enable assess if we look at quarter
H just so you guys get a an example of
what it's used we have enable asserts I
put this behind a macro this isn't
actually defined anywhere which means
currently it's also disabled so what we
could do is add it into the pre make
file of course so if we look at the pre
make file we have our defines
we could just easily just add that in
there I don't want it to find
we could have it there for kind of debug
but I'd rather define it and encourage
so what I'm going to do is inside
corridor H I'm going to say that if not
defiant edge said enable asserts or
rather you know what was it let's do it
this way if H said debug is defined then
I'm going to define H said enable assess
now technically speaking I don't want
this to be an F def I want it to be an
if okay that way right if H that enable
asserts is actually set to like one or
something like that then I can actually
if we look at the pre-med qual again if
it's been set at all right
then you can actually forcibly in the
build script set you know this to zero
right or to false or something like that
right doesn't matter usually zero what
that means is that this has in fact been
defined right but it's been defined to
zero which means this still is off right
but if you haven't defined it at all
that's where this code takes over and by
default turns it on so that's something
that I want to do in the future okay but
I want to do that specifically for other
things and in a separate episode so for
now this is just becoming if H said
debug is defined we always turn asserts
on and so now I says have been enabled
so I probably discussed this a little
bit more with what I said that before I
close it okay so that's that pull
request we didn't get to we'll get to
that next time but hopefully this was a
really good overview of kind of github
and how we can kind of collaborate on
Hazel together okay so I hope you guys
enjoyed that video if you did hit that
like button you can help support the
stories by going over to page from the
conference after the churner
huge thank you to everyone who helps
support the series hazel wouldn't be
here without you guys I promise you that
so thank you so much if you just help
support that series will get episodes
about a week early as well as also
access to a private development branch
in which I've already got a lot of stuff
developed and that's kind of the one
that I just go along with and do stuff
in my spare time next time I think we're
going to move on I would love maybe I'll
do pull requests next time I don't know
I'm really interested to see your
feedback for this episode you guys like
this kind of episode it's something that
we just have to do every now and then
just kind of a maintenance episode
because obviously we do end up kind of
building up a little bit of tech debt
and also I want to spend time
collaborating with you guys hopefully
this makes you feel more involved in
hazel so if for example you do want to
have a go at writing features that would
be great I'm sure that a lot of you will
probably not end up running it the way
that I want to write it and because
obviously I'm kind of trying to teach as
well I'll probably end up running in my
way kind of anyway but I will I'm happy
to review your stuff on these actual
videos and talk about why you know we
can talk about design you can you guys
can submit code in the form of issues or
pull requests or whatever and I can look
at it and I can we can kind of just talk
about why you know I might not do it
this way or maybe you guys will give me
great ideas right so that's what I want
to kind of encourage you this kind of
spirit of collaboration because together
you know we can build hazel and make it
pretty cool I will see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]